PREGAME, CASEY CAN SEE GUKINGS.
WE TALKED ABOUT HOW LIKE.
GOOD  THE PLAYERS TO
GIVE ANY LEEWAWA WHAT
SURVIVES.
HURRY CO
HAS SOME ROOM.
PULOCK GOOD PLAYER.
>> AJ: IT'S NOT EVEN SIX
ZONE TIME RIGHT HERE.
KEMPE.
WHAT A GOOD SAFE.
AND .
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMEBODY THE
ISLANDER IS TRYING TO WORRY
ABOUT.
KEMPE IS RIGHT IN  FOR QUIT
IN MY FIELD.
THE SECOND PICK OF THE 2020
DRAFT GETS TALK GUY WHO USES
THE SIDES.
LOOK AT THE SEPARATION. IN
ATTENDANCE.
GOOD FIRST.
FOFO
SECOND POST.T.PASSING, TOO.
IT HAS BEEN INTERESTING TO PETE
>> AJ: IS THE LAST CHANCE BY
HIM. IN FRONT!
BARZAL! TO THE OUT THIS.
CERTAINLY THAT HE
30 GOALSCORER.
HE HAD
PETERSEN BY THE LOCKER.
>> John: 17 THE START OF THE
YEAR.  AT.
>> John: SAVED!
THE KINGS LOOK TO THE M TRYING
OVER.
HE GOES DOWN.
THE PUCK GOES UP.
STAR, ADRIAN
THE SWEDE, WITH HIS 18th GOAL
OF THE YEAR, AND KINGS FANS CAN
AND THE FINISH WITH CASEY L